all right Alessandro and Jake about more
like last week people released a ton of
Red Dead previews for Red Dead
Redemption - they got to play about 90
minutes the game they saw the train
robbery and then as a little bit of the
open world so people have to talk about
it there's a lot to unpack
we were actually lucky enough to see an
extra like three and a half hours or so
we played right from the beginning the
game we came into the demo a rockstar
had the game paused on the intro screen
we're not gonna spoil anything with
specific characters or events we'll talk
about general tone and how it might
compared to GTA 5 or something but we
played for about two hours in beginning
and then more open the world Jake I
don't know like without spoiling too
much the beginning of the game what did
it feel like to you like you think it
did a good job of intro and unit that's
the vast array of new ideas in this game
yet to be honest it reminded me a lot of
the beginning of GTA 5 when you start
out in north yankton and you're robbing
that Bank it kind of introduces you to
the gameplay mechanics the driving the
aiming all those kind of systems and is
very similar to that and that you are
kind of stuck in a blizzard and you're
forced to I mean they they that's pretty
much their opportunity to let you try
out all these different systems they
kind of walk you through the different
features that the game has so very
similar except stretched out a lot it's
a lot longer because there's a lot more
to this game yeah and it sets up like
the general story like I mean you've
seen in trailers the dying days of the
you know the Wild West the lawless
frontier it's coming to an end you're
meeting people you know we're not gonna
you are meeting a bunch of people like
you got Dutch you got Bill Williamson
you've got like a beers Xavier zwei TLAs
and as well so you're meeting your gang
and whatnot and it's kind of like
entering you to all these ideas but also
I think the tutorial is pretty important
because it's ensuring you to how many
different social interactions you have
how much how many layers of detail there
is to how you're interacting with this
world and more importantly I think with
the Red Dead Redemption to its how the
world reacts to you which is something
that we say open-world games do but
based on our preview this is it is
actually doing that this time
but I lost honor I don't know like did
you feel throughout the time we were
playing the game like were you
overwhelmed by the amount of things you
could do or do you think it ease you
into it based on those first few hours
like how are you feeling I think the
intro definitely
really helps like sort of easing us into
the new mechanic so it was set during a
blizzard which by the way I really
appreciate that West earnest or you like
utilizing snow because that's something
that's not really see often like Western
fiction like April 8 exactly or like you
know even like an older film like the
great silence you know which it was a
classic western set in the snow but um
setting it in sort of a blizzard for one
of the pace was a lot slower because we
were you know stuck in that blizzard and
you know we were just sort of moving
very slowly and being very careful but
also it sort of clued us in on some of
the core mechanics of the actual core
systems for the game like a you know you
have to keep track of like you know your
body temperature and stamina you know
and also the type of stuff you're
wearing yeah it was a very clever way of
which was sort of easing us into the
sort of new mechanics of the game yeah
it's interesting too because a lot of
people who played it they were
mentioning how or didn't play the full
thing you know they played that hour and
a half they were saying how overwhelming
it is and it was definitely overwhelming
for us as well but having that extra
like two hours or whatever to go through
that tutorial if I mean like it helped a
lot and it really put into perspective
how different this game is compared to
previous rockstar games and to most
open-world games we see today I was more
actually if I'm being honest I was more
overwhelmed by it sort of the the scope
of the world itself cuz it seemed a lot
more broad in like more grand than the
original game and we definitely got to
see that while we were actually
exploring that first section where we're
going through the mountains and sort of
seeing the landscape which looked
fantastic the way it subtly changes from
one biome to the next is is pretty
amazing to see like it'll be just like
that's very a snow-covered landscape and
all of a sudden you'll see a few trees
and then like the you'll all of a sudden
be in the middle of forest and of course
like you're coming across different
characters that you're getting missions
from what about how like you came across
sidequest
Jake you went into a town at one point
do you want to tell us like some of the
things that happened there Jake was
there we were handing the controller
back and forth and Jake was quickly
became the outlaw of us I want to start
at the beginning before I get to this
the town where I just run my horse into
another car and the guy was like what
the f
yeah and I like tried to calm him down
and he's like forget it and he just kept
getting more and more annoyed and I kept
trying to calm him down and then he left
then I started killing people and I was
like running around trying to like stop
witnesses
yeah it just like kept snowballing like
a socially trigger left trigger you can
cool him you can threaten him the
calming is pretty much like dude chill
out and then like that pissed him off
more yeah and then like you someone
witnessed it when you two got that
gunfight so you had to go chase them
down that happened to me as well a
member I think this dude's wife saw me
kill him and I had to do it it wasn't
out of like any like coldness of my
heart
she ran away so I like fired a warning
shot and then pointed my gun at her and
she's like don't worry I won't tell
anybody and then she left and she still
told the sheriff this nothing I
should've shot this person in the face
like that's what it feels like these
NPCs are actually like I think other
people have said it it's kind of
elevating the small emergent miscellany
in other games they'll be just like
these miscellaneous quests but it's
elevating those like small encounters
onto the like the same level as main
story missions they feel not authored
like it doesn't feel like rockstars hand
is there but like I think they're doing
it so well that it feels like they're
it's just you like playing this world
but then you got like I don't know like
you went toward town and like a few more
things well I mean I'm kind of jumping
ahead a little bit but also the
interaction I had with the guy from
Mexico is just like hey do you want to
have a shooting competition yeah and I
was like sure and I lost and he's like
alright five bucks and I just figured
like in most games would be like minus
five dollars you gave him up so I
figured that'd happen and I just walked
away he's like what the hell like
where's my money and I was like what you
think what and then he pulled out his
gun and I just shot him a bunch yeah a
bunch eyes when he fell down and like
got back up finally and they took all
his money too he had one from you know
presumably betting other people yeah
yeah it was a bet you like he's like you
shook on it where's my money you're like
I thought I gave it to you and you're
about to get back on your horse but and
that's something you just came across
like it's it's funny because we've been
you've seen open-world games or like
games in general kind of going toward
this a player driven emergent gameplay
this game really now that I was kind of
riding my horse through a forest all of
a sudden I hear like this choking or
like this retching
and all the sudden this guy stumbles out
of this woods like with vomit you could
see vomit all over shirt you know like I
walk up to him I'm like what's wrong and
he's like please give me some medicine I
give him medicine and as he's like
feeling better immediately he's like oh
man I was trying to find something to
trip with don't eat the pink flowers
they're poisonous but I didn't get
anything out of that question there was
no monetary reward there was no gear or
anything there was no new quest line
that just happened and he walked away
and we were all I got I don't know what
that was about
and then you came across a guy in a bear
trap right yeah we found a guy like in
the middle of the woods like just in a
bear trap and of course you can use the
social trigger and for some reason like
I thought was appropriate I just said
hey man because he's like bleeding out
also he's like hey what's wrong
but of course we could help him like you
know get him out and you'd be grateful
but actually one of my favorite moments
like from our demo was you'll know
exactly when I talk about the guy on the
hill like you know in his tent and when
we encountered him like this was like in
the evening and the rain was starting to
come down and we went up to him and
first thing he said was hey man you have
a girlfriend I was look and I was like
we're yeah I was very weirded out by it
and I think all of us were but so I
decided to react negatively and I think
this is maybe one of the rare cases were
doing one sort of response will get the
opposite from most people like it
because I responded negatively the whole
time and kept going he kept going and it
got more more weird because he started
talking about how he would spy on you
know sort of lonely women in the but
there's one specific widow right yeah
and we actually got a notification in
our log saying you know hey there's this
cabin nearby maybe we should check it
out yeah so eventually I just had enough
and I shot the guy because he was total
creep and that after that we saw another
kid look we saw a cabin down the hill
and we I guess at first we thought it
was related so we just decided to go
down there and check it out and the rain
was coming down it was totally dark and
the only thing that was giving us light
was sort of the lanterns around the
cabin and so we went into the cabin and
we had to break down the door because it
was locked so as soon as we got in
his entire family was dead they were
like their bodies were like decomposing
and you know it was a really eerie scene
seeing that to clarify that there they
were just like dead NPC bodies yeah they
were rotting bodies like oh this didn't
just happen yeah I could tell that it
was like a long time ago
yeah and experiencing that and along
with the the creeper on the hill like
you know even though those are totally
isolated encounters like you know
experiencing that one after the other
sort of created the sort of cohesive
like story like you know just the the
wilderness can be really creepy
yeah and like you mentioned how a
notification popped up and like the way
they justify that it's pretty much
Arthur Morton writing in his journal so
like you can read his journal and hear
about like something that went down in
Blackwater or whatever that like screwed
with the gang and they haven't forgotten
about it or you made sketches to it yeah
he sketches stuff it's kind of like it's
a much more in-depth like Nathan Drake
doesn't in uncharted kind of something
like that
also Eleanor Eleanor same thing yeah
exactly um was it Cole Phelps and that
does it he it all like I like what you
said about it the thing that struck me
from these like five hours we played in
the course like this one morning we went
over to hang out the rock star it felt
it didn't feel like oh we did three
story quests we did three side quests we
did like four miscellaneous quests it's
like no we just played for five hours
and then we have a story about those
five hours I don't have an individual
like it's not just mission and then
traveling in that mission it's you know
but there raveling itself is part of the
game and you know like Zelda breath the
wild got toward that more toward that
you know like I mean like GTA v was
trying that to some extent you know but
like now it feels more like again they
kind of elevate that the side quests up
onto the same level as the main story to
the point where like you don't feel like
you're missing out if you're doing this
minor quest because you have no idea
what's gonna come out of it yeah I mean
I think breadth of the wild is like a
good comparison in that that game is so
based around emerging gameplay and the
things that happen but I think the
biggest difference that Rockstar is
doing is that that emergent gameplay
extends to those interactions that you
come across like it's gonna play out
differently for everyone depending on
whether or not your gun is up whether
you're covered in mud whether you're
bloody like depending on what situation
like is he in a bear trap like now I'm
gonna respond
differently I'm not entirely sure like
how random or how varied those will
actually be when the game came comes out
but based on like the five hours we
played just seeing like the diversity of
those interactions was staggering it's
funny because you know you talk about
like how when you look at like divinity
original sin 2 as an RPG it's it's
obviously very gamey it's turn-based
combat and whatnot and like it's an
isometric view but to a certain extent
like it's hard to find the boundaries of
what you can't do it felt very much like
each small thing was connected in the
story like every little detail was
connected and like it's easy to say it's
a detailed world but it's also just like
how each layer it's not it doesn't feel
layered it feels like it's just one big
game that all matters and it was the
most impressive thing yeah even like
small things which I think people have
already talked about by now but even
small things like how much you eat like
whether or not you keep yourself clean
like that we'll all like feed into
something like interactions with NPCs or
whatever and I think that is super
interesting yeah and even just it's fun
to just travel on your horse and you can
like he's also funny to Biff it on to
talk about yeah what did I broke the
horse's legs on the next thing cuz I
went off a cliff and I hurt myself and
yeah you get those cores and the horses
stamina and health quarters down all the
way yeah I gotta meet you Aaron you had
the use of special items all ossandra
like ran into a tree like it was like it
was like one of those classic moments
where like ah right in most games it's
not gonna hit the tree if he's just
gonna win it yeah itself or it's just
gonna be awkward but no I might hit that
tree I felt so bad for the horse too
because I was like that was a really bad
hit I'm so sorry I really really like
that the West very the world itself very
much it sounds cliche but it is a
character it's interacting with you and
it's it's one thing to play be playing
open-world games and for the developer
to make a world that makes you react to
it it's another thing like when we
played Red Dead that the world feels
like it's reacting to you and that's
something we've always liked not always
best something we've been saying about
open-world games yeah but again it's
kind of like you know like sometimes it
feels like we're being hyperbolic like
the world isn't actually reacting to you
it's not dynamic or immersive it feels
like Red Dead is earning those cliched
terms we've been using for the last like
five
years and that's only based on five
hours like who knows October 26 could
roll around in the game could be okay
but based on what we play it it seems
pretty impressive like everything we saw
I just felt like it was it was reacting
to our choice it's not just like binary
like Paragon renegade choices like oh I
forgot that I picked up that gun and
that was that dude's gun so now he's
pissed like yeah another interesting
little tidbit that happened was in that
final mission I played I don't know if
you remember but there was that one guys
like I got a P and they were like
telling you you should like sneak up on
ya so I start to sneak up on him and
they're still having a conversation I
didn't realize it he was looking right
yeah he was like still talking to his
two other friends or whatever and you
were like trying to stop me like you
should wait until they're done talking
but I didn't hear you and went up and
stabbed him and they reacted and I was
like why did they react like I they
weren't looking but of course like it's
supposed to be more grounded he was
mid-sentence talking to his friends his
friends were like what the [ __ ] just
yeah he's like remember that time back
then Arthur just for the knife is there
and that's the thing like pre breath of
the wild maybe again like to make a not
so obvious comparison whatever but like
I don't think I would have thought of
that but I think that was like pretty
far into our demo so when I think we
were all kind of a aside from you at
that party I'm joking we were all a tune
to the fact that this game is accounting
for everything and like you know you've
got a ton of Rockstar developers working
on this game it's fair to assume there's
gonna be polished and there's gonna be
like they're gonna account for those
decisions but it's not when we say
player choice it's not even like this
game is more of a role-playing game than
like most RPGs nowadays like there again
there's like divinity is there but most
times we say RPG we mean just
progression and binary choices and
whatnot or branching choices this
doesn't feel like a branching storyline
it feels like it's just like this
measure web of possible things
come across and it feels really daunting
in a good way so far I think it also
speaks to the fact that you know
Rockstar is a very particular way of
approaching open-world games you know
even though this is a sequel to Red Dead
Redemption
it's also on a mechanical level sequel
to Grand Theft Auto 5 and pretty much
every other game that they've also
worked on in the past they've even
reincorporated the sort of sex appeal
aspect from san andreas like where other
characters will react to you know
basically how you present yourself
during one moment I think during the bar
fight you know when one of the NPC
characters said you know okay
okay pretty boy yeah and Jake had just
shaved the room his hair and stuff and
then the Rockstar was telling us if you
let your hair grow out too much and if
you eat too much and you don't you don't
clean up your gang members and your camp
members will start being like dude yes
this hygiene thing is a problem yes it's
on us I yeah like hey like clean up you
smell bad or you're bringing down morale
so like on a wild level the game is
accounting for player choice but it's
also accounting for a lack of players
like you can't you it's like you're not
just like exploring the world that this
point you're being lazy and the game is
accounting for that and that's pretty
impressive
and yeah it's worth considering that
this is the biggest gap that rockstars
ever had between major releases like GTA
5 was 2013 since their founding and what
98 or something they haven't had this
big of a gap between releases and so far
we could tell you know like how much
polish there is and how much time
they've put into it or how much work
they put into that time but uh got
exactly three more weeks from today
until we get to play the game and
release it on what ps4 Xbox one
you
[Music]